my guest tonight is a very talented
comedian and writer who has appeared
numerous times on our show
her debut our special girl daddy is
available now
on hbo max and it's fantastic please
welcome
beth stelling beth how are you i'm good
i'm so happy to see you
don't have a human yeah another human
so see your bar is that low you're not
necessarily happy to see conan o'brien
just any human will do
i should have taken that back i've
written i love conan here
on this board in preparation for this
big event i'm sure you can see it
clearly
no no well it's there just trust that
it's there
i wrote it in this marker not permanent
marker
i'm okay all right oops i dropped it
you know um i'm a big fan of yours
uh huge fan of yours and we
uh have been very anxious at team coco
to support
your standup special in any way possible
that's something that's been a labor of
love for us
you know we've really wanted to get the
word out normally i would pay for you to
have a giant best-selling billboard in
times square i'd pay for that out of my
own pocket gladly
but what good you gonna do during a
pandemic
you've employed some novel techniques
like you've you
you've been using my friends and family
to handle some grassroots
marketing efforts yeah
like you had someone write the details
of my special on a sidewalk in chalk
which i mean one thunderstorm and that's
gone conan
i know but look first of all i thought
that four-year-old did a very good job
i think it looked pretty good and yeah
so it'll last until the next rainstorm
but you know what all publicity is good
publicity
okay well-traveled sidewalk
you also had a friend of mine hang a
banner outside of her house
and she lives on a country road so i
just feel like no one
we needed that sign at the smash mouth
concert you know like i just feel like
i need your head and i looked into that
i looked into having it hung
at the smash mouth uh concert and the
people
they said it was unsafe the the people
that hang spines
so that's why they hung out on that
rural country road in north carolina
you even hired my dad the owner and sole
operator of stars on call
in orlando and he had him do a
commercial
that this is actually real
this is your dad your dad did that's my
father
yeah brother let's take a look at this
clip now of your dad promoting
uh girl daddy let's take a look
bestelling
girl daddy hbo max
keep smiling and watch it
what's his deal what is the deal with
that man
look he does live roadside commercials
or character directions
so he stands in front of businesses that
are paying him to get people
inside and maybe online
is that and is it work does he i would
think i mean some people he might
frighten some people from going into it
that's a very valid point um sometimes
he was on the news he was on far out on
fox and they did say
when they asked the business owners that
up to and then they gave some sort of
percentage and i don't know how they
reached that percentage uh
but that 75 percent more people entered
than if
or weren't out front so yeah i guess you
could say it's working
i actually have one more request oh yeah
i just feel like
the least you could do for me now is
where this girl that he had that i sent
over to you
to largo this is nice i'll wear this
around
this it's adjustable this will get you'd
better be adjustable because
yeah it no it's actually on the highest
setting
i have a massive skull you have a big
brain
i have my dad would say my dad always
said because i had a big head it was
because i had a big brain
so i'm going to pass that on to you are
you uh
are you close to your dad you guys close
yeah i mean
look i feel like you can love a parent
and not always see eye to eye you know
he and i don't necessarily agree on
women's autonomy for example so
i like to donate to planned parenthood
in his name
oh yeah
i performed uh i performed for them a
couple times as well
isn't it weird for some reason comics
always get booked to perform at charity
events
yeah i've done it i have to say
i've done uh charity events before
and it's almost as if the people booking
it don't understand what comedy is
because i always want to say to them
afterwards
comedy needs some kind of context you
know
you need the room has to be prepared for
comedy
and sometimes if it's a really dark
charity
they don't prepare the room in any way
have you had that happen
oh my gosh yeah one year planned
parenthood asked me to come perform
at their fundraiser called the birds and
bees bash it's like it was in santa
barbara california
it was a bunch of rich old people
gathered together to
throw money at the cause beautiful thing
so it's like this swanky event
and i've slept on a skirt which is
obviously a big deal for me
and so it's in this beautiful banquet
hall and they sent me down in the back
next to joanna kearns you know who that
is right
uh she's a sitcom actress was she uh
what was she on
she was mrs seaver from growing things
oh okay miss uh yeah growing growing
pains i'm a little old for growing pains
uh but okay i uh i do kind of remember
that show i know who she is yes
yeah i was so excited and i sat down and
she explained that she's gonna give the
keynote speech and then she'll bring me
up to do 15 minutes of stand up so
joanna's up there talking about planned
parenthood what it means to her and her
family
and a woman in the back of the banquet
hole next to me at our table
starts to have a heart attack oh
yeah so joanna is just she just keeps
talking because she doesn't know what's
going on in the back of the room
just like i can't always know what's
going on in the back of every room i'm
performing in
people could be in the kitchen right now
making sweet sweet love and i would have
no clue
especially if it was like super slow
like i like wouldn't be able to hear him
so joanna is up here talking this
woman's having a heart attack
i'm watching her have a heart attack but
i'm also thinking like
what jokes am i gonna tell right right
and then an ambulance comes very quickly
almost as if they knew there was like a
gathering of olds and they just like
parked on the corner
so they rush in whenever it's an
ambulance that drives around it if it
sees like eight or more
old people gather in one spot it waits
there for 10 minutes
because they know they know something's
going to go down
that or a garage sale uh-oh how did that
just happen did you hear that
no oh someone just tried to call and i
went to my computer
anyway so the ambulance comes
very quickly they rush in they put this
woman on a stretcher because it was a
heart attack
but it was like a low key heart attack
she fell out of her chair and her
husband was worried
but as they're wheeling around past our
table towards the door she looks at us
and she says
i'm so sorry i'm fine i'm so
sorry which like might be the epitome of
being
a woman she's like i'm sorry i
interrupted with a heart attack i'm
happy to die if that helps i really will
i'll go die
so this is when they have her outside
the door
and just then joanna kearns leans into
the microphone and she says
who's ready for some stand-up comedy and
i'm in the back of the room like
so i get up i'm weaving my way through
the tables and my dumb skirt
the woman who's planned the event
intercepts me
she puts her hand on my shoulder she's
panicked and she's like i don't know
maybe you should do less time like five
minutes or something i was like
lady i'm doing 15. you know so i get up
there
in front of everyone felt like i really
needed to address the situation
yes someone just had a heart attack you
got it right
right right so i get up in front of
everybody and i just say
wow i've done a lot of things to get out
of donating money
but never that not everybody laughed
you know it took it was it was a while
it was potentially too soon my dad
however
very proud i bombed a planned parenthood
and
if he had been there would have been so
happy
you know i uh i think i
i don't know if i can top that but i
have something that was equally rough
where i did a benefit
and uh it was um you know for
people in the military and so the whole
audience was packed with
you know people who had served in the
military
very recently and and come back from
afghanistan
or iraq and it was it was intense they
showed this really intense film
and then an honor guard came out and
they said
now we remember our fallen brothers and
they played taps
on a bugle and then right after they
finished playing taps
of a voice on the uh on the microphone
said
ladies and gentlemen conan o'brien
i just i walked out there
people are crying their heads are bowed
oh no we need time between that
yes and mr goofy you need something
something a little light something a
little someone comes out with a
harmonica
and plays out monica you know i'm gonna
pitch jock jams you know just
infuse the room with some high energy
jock jams you really think that's a
problem up the jam
pump it up yeah just blow out the room
with some hot tunes
no you can't follow taps with jock jams
you know let me ask you a question did
you tidy up at all before you got on
national television with me beth look at
you did you do any
did you think at all like i should
probably
maybe try and straighten it up a little
bit
did you give it any thought okay
i got some what do i got there's a shirt
on a chair
i have some laundry over in that corner
uh-huh it's just to prove it
it does say oh look at that
conan that's is that a heart or a butt
it's a butt it looked like a butt to me
that's actually
a perfect rendering of your butt
i memorized it that is what my yeah
sadly
my wife will attest drawn to scale he
has seen
my butt and uh that's that's about it
it's actual size
um i saw you have a cello is that a
cello you have in the background
yeah you want me to that's what i that's
what i could have put between you and
taps
a little a little ode to joy from me on
there
yeah well it's funny because you have
you're actually in a much nicer
room than i thought you were you just
chose
you look fantastic don't get me wrong
you look lovely but the
the room is so much nicer you chose this
this terrible angle because you know
what
you are in the most depressing corner of
your house you know i usually have a
here's a beautiful
thing i usually have bean bag chairs but
they're too hot
they're too hot yeah it's too hot for a
beanbag chair right now
oh i thought you meant like too sexy
no bean bag chairs but they're just too
sexy
can't no one can handle it look you have
a lovely place
this is a fan oh that's your yeah that's
great oh look at you go you go
[Applause]
this has turned into a tour yeah i
should have done this
this is fantastic i should have been
right here that's fair
see every everything we've seen is much
nicer than what you do
so i'm sorry i'm just telling you
okay well we learned a lesson i think we
did
i'm going to change who i am yeah no no
no just the room i'm in
the fan the fan is great by the way that
fan is just
killer that's that's the new look for
you thank you
flowing always wind blown flowing you
have that going for you too without even
the fan
i'm just going for this now i'm gonna
it's pretty soon
it's gonna come straight down here and
i'm gonna have to cut out a little
window right here
that's what i'm gonna do um listen
i wanna congratulate you again on your
hilarious special
thank you really funny and uh there's
also thank you for making it
well you know i appreciate you i
i appreciate you being so funny and and
being so talented and
girl daddy look at that even a hat
hbo max watch it please
we'd love it if you watched it yeah
critics love it it's great yeah twins
all right i'll put mine on too and we
called your mom podcast is available
wherever you get
your podcasts keep on keeping busy
i will all right thank you beth thank
you
appreciate you